>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: WELCOME BACK TO "THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE."
MORE OF MY EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW
WITH THE PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY
RUDY GIULIANI.
TIMES" A BIG PIECE TODAY IS A
NUGGET YOU HAVE TO SEARCH FOR
THAT SAYS:
NOTHING PUBLICLY DISCLOSED TIES
TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN OR THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF TO THESE
DEALINGS WITH THE RUSSIANS.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK PAST THE
HEADLINE ALL THE WAY TO THAT.
>> THAT'S THE TRUTH FROM DAY 1.
IT'S TRUE TODAY.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY EVIDENCE OF
THAT.
IT'S A SHAME THAT THEY HAVE --
THEY WON'T ANSWER CONGRESS ON
HOW MUCH MONEY THIS IS COSTING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT'S COSTING THEM A FORTUNE.
>> Laura: YOU GET A SENSE THEY
WILL FOCUS IN ON SOME TYPE OF
OBSTRUCTION CLAIM.
>> TO WHAT TO RECOMMEND
IMPEACHMENT.
THEY DON'T GET TO DO THAT.
THEY GET TO SEND A REPORT TOROSE
ROSE ON WHAT THEY FOUND.
I GUESS THEY COULD INCLUDE A
RECOMMENDATION, BUT THEY SHOULD
NOT.
>> Laura: OR THE FACTS THAT
WOULD INDICATE THE ELEMENTS OF
THE CRIME.
>> WE CAN PRODUCE A MEMO THAT
REBUTS THEM ALL 1,000%.
>> Laura: THE TRUMP TOWER
MEETINGS THERE IS CONFUSION
THERE.
>> HE WAS NOT PRESIDENT THEN.
>> Laura: AND DONALD TRUMP JR.
NOTES OF HIS TALK CAME OUT
TODAY.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE RELEASED
THE NOTES.
HE SAID HE DID NOT HAVE A MEMORY
ABOUT TALKING TO HIS FATHER
SPECIFICALLY.
THEY ARE FOCUSSING ON THIS
BLOCKED CALL HE MADE THAT DAY.
HE DOESN'T REMEMBER WHETHER IT
WAS TO HIS FATHER OR NOT.
THAT'S THE THEORY THEY ARE
SPINNING OUT.
IN THE OFFICE, IT WOULD BE EASY
FOR HIM --
>> Laura: JUNE 26th.
>> AND THAT'S WHEN I JOINED THE
CAMPAIGN.
NOBODY WILL FOCUS ON A RUSSIAN
WOMAN WHO SAID SHE HAD
INFORMATION ABOUT HILLARY.
SHE WANTS TO NEGOTIATE SANCTIONS
AND THEY THROW HER OUT.
WHEN SHE WANTS TO MEET AGAIN,
THEY DON'T MEET WITH HER.
I WOULD NOT REMEMBER THAT.
I HAVE PEOPLE COMING UP TO ME
SAYING ALL KINDS OF THINGS ABOUT
HILLARY.
I BELIEVE ALMOST ANYTHING ABOUT
I SAY GET RID OF THEM.
>> Laura: THE CNN HEADLINES SAID
THEY WERE LOOKING FOR DIRT ON
HILLARY CLINTON?
>> AND THEY WERE NOT LOOKING FOR
DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP.
WHEN I RAN, THEY WERE LOOKING
FOR DIRT ON ME EVERY DAY.
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD NOT.
BUT YOU DO IT.
THERE IS NOTHING ILLEGAL ABOUT
THAT.
EVEN IF IT COMES FROM A RUSSIAN
OR A GERMAN OR AN AMERICAN, IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
THEY NEVER USED IT.
THAT'S THE MAIN THING.
THEY REJECTED IT.
IF THERE WAS COLLUSION WITH THE
RUSSIANS THEY WOULD HAVE USED
IT.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK IN THE
END WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALL OF THE
MAIN FLASH POINTS, THE TRUMP
TOWER MEETING AND THE STORMY
DANIELS PAYMENT AND THE RAID ON
MANAFORT AND THE RAID ON COHEN,
IS THERE ANY ONE PART THAT
CONCERNS YOU MORE THAN OTHER
PARTS OF THAT?
>> YES, THE INABILITY TO REACH A
CONCLUSION THAT IS OBVIOUS.
THEIR UNWILLINGNESS TO RECOGNIZE
THE DAMAGE THIS DOES TO OUR
COUNTRY ALL OVER THE WORLD.
THERE IS NO REASON FOR THIS
INVESTIGATION.
THERE WAS NEVER A GOOD REASON
FOR IT.
THIS WAS ENGINEERED BY COMEY
WITH THE INTERVIEW THING HE
WROTE THAT HE SHOULD NEVER
REVEALED.
HE LEAKED IT ILLEGALLY THROUGH A
PROFESSOR.
>> Laura: THE DOJ IS RELEASING
THOSE DOCUMENTS ON THAT
PARTICULAR PROFESSOR.
>> COMEY SHOULD BE UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
CLINTON WANTED HIM FIRED BEFORE
WE DID FOR WHAT HE DID TO HER.
THAT WAS UNETHICAL INCRIMINATING
HER.
THEN THIS SPECIOUS ARGUMENT SHE
SHOULD NOT BE PROSECUTED.
>> Laura: DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE
HOW THESE THINGS TEND TO GO?
THERE IS ANY CHANCE THAT BOB
MUELLER GAVE IMMUNITY TO JIM
COMEY?
>> NO, I DON'T.
I HAVE NO IDEA IF HE GAVE HIM
IMMUNITY.
I DON'T KNOW WHY HE IS NOT BEING
INVESTIGATED.
THAT TROUBLES US.
A LOT OF THE PRESIDENT'S
STATEMENTS CONTRADICT COMEY.
THEY ARE MORE LOGICAL THAN
COMEY'S.
IF YOU WANT TO JUST BELIEVE
COMEY, THEN YOU ARE WALKING INTO
A TRAP.
COMEY HASN'T BEEN INVESTIGATED.
I DON'T THINK WE WOULD SIT DOWN
FOR AN INTERVIEW UNLESS COMEY
WAS INVESTIGATED IN THE SAME
WAY.
>> Laura: GOLDBERG, A FORMER
TRUMP LAWYER.
I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF HIM?
>> YES, I TRIED CASES AGAINST
HIM.
I TOLD HIM I DIDN'T THINK THAT
GIULIANI WAS THE RIGHT PERSON
FOR HIM TO SELECT.
I THOUGHT THERE WERE MUCH BETTER
PEOPLE HE BEING USE IN TERMS OF
NEGOTIATING CAN MUELLER.
>> I GUESS I BET HIM TOO MANY
TIMES.
[LAUGHING].
HE IS GETTING A LITTLE OLD.
THE ONLY THING I HAVE IS THE
PRESIDENT TRUSTS ME AND I TRUST
THE PRESIDENT.
I HAVE HIS BACK IN THE RIGHT
WAY.
I WOULD REPRESENT ANY PRESIDENT
PUT UNDER THIS TORTURE.
THIS IS NOT RIGHT FOR THE
COUNTRY.
I AM DOING THIS PRO-BONO BECAUSE
I BELIEVE THIS IS JUST PLAIN
WRONG.
>> Laura: THE TOLL THIS TAKES ON
THE FAMILY.
YOU MENTIONED IVANKA.
YOU SAID JARED WAS DISPOSABLE.
>> I WAS KIDDING AROUND.
JARED LOVED IT.
HE SAID DID MY WIFE TELL ME TO
SAY THAT?
I SAID NO, I AM DISPOSABLE TOO.
>> Laura: YOU ARE NOT WORRIED
ABOUT THE EXPOSURE BECAUSE OF
THE MEETING WITH THE RUSSIAN
BANKER.
>> NONE WAS ABOUT GETTING HER
EMAILS.
IT WAS DIRTY INFORMATION THEY
ALLEGED TO HAVE.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE IT.
END OF STORY.
>> Laura: THE MEETING JARED HAD
WITH THE RUSSIAN BANK?
>> THAT'S A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
BUSINESS THING.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
COLLUSION WITH THE RUSSIANS.
THE ELECTION WAS OVER.
>> Laura: IF YOU ORDERED A WHITE
RUSSIAN HERE, YOU WOULD NUMBER
TROUBLE.
>> I HAVE NOT BEEN IN RUSSIA IN
4 OR 5 YEARS.
THANK GOD.
>> Laura: DO YOU HAVE ANY
CONCERN THAT THERE IS NO REAL
WAY AT THIS POINT TO GET A FAIR
OUTCOME BY A SPECIAL COUNSEL
THAT MAY BEGUN AND NAMED ON
SPEARIOUS GROUNDS?
>> I THINK WE WILL BE INDICATED
IN COURT.
>> Laura: YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
THE COURT WITH THE PRESIDENT.
>> NO.
CHALLENGING THE LOGISTICS OF
THEIR INVESTIGATION AND THEIR
AUTHORITY AND THE WAY THEY
SPANED IT OUT SO MUCH.
>> Laura: YOU MAINTAIN THAT THE
EXPANSION OF THE PROBE IS
ILLEGITIMATE.
>> WHAT THEY DID WITH MANAFORT
AND WITH MICHAEL COHEN.
ALL OF THE ILLEGITIMATE THINGS
THEY HAVE DONE.
POSSIBLY PLACING A SPY IN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE AREAS
WHERE INDICTMENTS WERE
DISMISSED.
SOME OF THESE SAME PEOPLE HAVE
DONE IT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT BOB WAS
THINKING ABOUT HIRING SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE.
>> Laura: HOPE HICKS' NAME WAS
THROWN AROUND IN THE TRUMP TOWER
MEETING.
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT HIS
CONVERSATIONS AT ALL?
>> THOSE STATEMENTS WERE NOT
UNDER OATH.
THAT WOULD BE REALLY CHEAP.
>> Laura: HE IS TURNING THE
SCREWS ON PEOPLE AS JUDGE ELLIS
SAID.
NOT BECAUSE HE THINKS ABOUT
MANAFORT.
HE CARES ABOUT GETTING TO TRUMP.
>> HOW COULD MANAFORT IN 2004
HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH THIS?
>> Laura: MANAFORT IS DIFFERENT
FROM A 30-YEAR-OLD OR A
25-YEAR-OLD WHO IS LIKE I WON'T
LOSE MY LIVELIHOOD.
YOU KNOW HOW THEY OPERATE.
YOU WERE A PROSECUTOR.
>> I WORKED WITH HOPE.
>> Laura: SHE IS FANTASTIC.
>> SHE IS NOT GOING TO LIE.
>> Laura: NO, NO, I AM JUST
USING THAT AS AN EXAMPLE.
YOU KNOW HOW THEY WORK.
>> IF THEY DID THAT TO HER THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WOULD HAVE TO
STEP IN AND ACT.
THAT'S TOTAL INJUSTICE.
THEY HAVE DONE A FEW INJUSTICES
BUT NOT AS BAD AS THAT NOW.
>> Laura: THE TIMELINE FOR THIS
TO WRAP UP?
>> THEY SHOULD DO IT TODAY.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
I THINK THEY HAVE THE FACTS ON
WHICH THEY CAN WRITE THEIR
REPORT.
IT WAS A FAIR REPORT, FINE.
RIGHT.
IF YOU RIGHT AN UNFAIR REPORT,
WRITE IT AND WE WILL COMPAT IT.
WE ARE READY TO RIP IT APART AND
RIP THEM APART IF THAT'S WHAT
THEY WANT.
WE WOULD RATHER PEACEFULLY